WELCOME USC HEAD BASKETBALL
COACH ANDY AND FIELD TO THE
SHOW, COACH. HOW ARE YOU
DOING? VERY WELL. THANK YOU.
WELL I CAN IMAGINE.
ON GETTING BACK TO THE SWEET
16. ONCE AGAIN, MY FRIEND
WHAT AN IMPRESSIVE
PERFORMANCE BY YOU GUYS LAST
NIGHT AGAINST KANSAS YOU BEAT
THEM BY 34 POINTS THAT NEVER
LOST BY MORE THAN 18
IN THE TOURNAMENT.
TAKEN DOWN ONE OF THE TRUE
BLUE BLOODS OF COLLEGE
BASKETBALL. WHAT POINT DID
YOU KNOW YOU GUYS REALLY HAD
IT GOING?
WELL, KANSAS IS NEVER OUT OF
A GAME. THEY'RE SO GOOD
DEFENSIVELY ALL SEASON THAT
THEY ARE EXPLOSIVE OFFENSE
ALI AND THEY'VE BEEN PLAYING
GREAT BASKETBALL. HE DID ONE
NINE OUT OF TEN COMING INTO
THE GAME. AND SO THEY WERE
PLAYING THEIR BEST BASKETBALL
AT THE END OF THE YEAR AND
THEY'RE BIG CENTER MCCORMICK
WAS PLAYING GREAT AND THEIR
GUARDS ARE SO TALENTED. SO
WE NEVER THOUGHT WE HAD THE
GAME UP UNTIL MAYBE ABOUT SIX
OR SEVEN MINUTES UP WHEN IT
BALLOONED UP TO 25 OR 30
POINTS. BUT EVEN AT HALF TIME,
WE'RE UP 19 AND THEY CAME
OUT AND MADE A QUICK RUN. I
HAD TO CALL TIMEOUT ABOUT 17
MINUTES LEFT AND SETTLE OUR
GUYS DOWN THAT THERE JUST TO
REMIND THEM THAT THIS THIS
GAME'S NOT OVER. WHAT WAS IT
EIGHT YEARS AGO. HE MADE THE
SWEET 16 AT FLORIDA GULF
COAST.
YEAH, THE EIGHT YEARS AGO.
YES. IT WAS A SPECIAL RUN BY
FGCU THE EAGLES WHAT GREAT
PLAYERS. WE HAD A LOT OF FUN.
HOW DOES THIS FEEL DIFFERENT
OR DOES IT WELL, IT'S TOTALLY
DIFFERENT. I WAS THERE TWO
YEARS. WE WERE A BRAND NEW
SCHOOL BRAND NEW PROGRAM. WE
JUST HAD THE SCHOOL JUST GONE
DIVISION ONE IN THE WAY THAT
THOSE PLAYERS CAME TOGETHER
AND THE EXCITING STYLE OF
PLAY THAT THEY HAD THIS IS
DIFFERENT BECAUSE OUR
COACHING STAFF CAME IN HERE
EIGHT YEARS AGO AND BUILT
THIS PROGRAM.
JASON HEART MY ASSOCIATE HEAD
COACH CHRIS CAP GO CURTIS
SCHULTZ. THEY'VE BEEN WITH ME
THE ENTIRE TIME AND SO TO SEE
BEING LAST PLACE IN THE
PAC-12 FOR TWO YEARS OR FIRST
TWO YEARS WERE FIVE AND
THIRTY ONE IN THE PAC-12 AND
WE WEREN'T WE'RE JUST
WEREN'T VERY GOOD. AND THEN
WE WERE ABLE TO RECRUIT AND
DEVELOP SOME PLAYERS AND HAVE
SOME SUCCESS YOUR ELASTIC SIX
YEARS. AND SO THIS IS A GREAT
GAME TO FOR OUR PROGRAM TO
SHOW HOW FAR THE USC PROGRAM
HAS COME. SO
WAS A LITTLE
ALL DIFFERENT FEELING THAN
THE FLORIDA GULF COAST RUN,
BUT AT THE SAME TIME ANY TIME
YOU CAN GO TO THE SWEET 16.
IT'S JUST SPECIAL FOR THE
PLAYERS. AND SO I'M I'M
REALLY HAPPY FOR OUR PLAYERS
RIGHT NOW BECAUSE THEY WORK
SO HARD TO GET HERE. YOU
TALKED ABOUT SOME OF YOUR
ASSISTANT COACHES, ERIC
MOBLEY AND AND JASON HEART
AND CHRIS CAP, CO AND COACH
DESMOND, WHICH ONE OF THOSE
GUYS WAS IT THAT BROUGHT YOUR
ATTENTION TO TWO CBS AND YOU
GUYS WERE UNDISCIPLINED.
WE
IT LUNCH AND COACH MOBLEY
PULLED HIS PHONE OUT TO WATCH
A GAME OR CHECK ON SOME
SCORES FROM THE TOURNAMENT
THIS IN THE AFTERNOON. WE
PLAYED THE LATE GAME. SO HE
LITERALLY TURNED HIS PHONE ON
TURN THE CBS AND AND IT BROKE
TO A STUDIO SHOW AND AND I
DON'T EVEN KNOW WHO SAID IT.
WE JUST HEARD IT. WE SAW AND
HEARD IT AND JUST SAID WE
WERE UNDISCIPLINED AND THEY
WERE PICKING KANSAS. SO LOOK
EVERYBODY HAS AN OPINION. WE
WERE JUST FORTUNATE TO PLAY
WELL LAST NIGHT AND AT LEAST
PLAY GOOD BASKETBALL. YEAH.
WELL, I
II LOVE THAT EVERYBODY HAS TO
FIND A CHIP, RIGHT? EVERYBODY
HAS TO HAVE SOMETHING TO HOLD
ON THEIR SHOULDER. TOM BRADY.
DOES IT MORE SO THAN ANYBODY
AND HE'S THE GREATEST
QUARTERBACK IN NFL HISTORY.
DID YOU USE THAT GUY? DID YOU
USE THAT AS FUEL? DID YOU
TALK TO YOUR TEAM ABOUT THAT?
NO, WE DIDN'T TALK TO THE
TEAM. WE ARE STAFFORD IT SO
OUR STAFF WAS WE WERE JUST A
LITTLE BIT MADE US VERY ANGRY
BECAUSE IF YOU LOOKED AT THE
KEN PALM NUMBERS WHICH SHOWS
DEFENSIVE AND OFFENSIVE
EFFICIENCY RIGHT RANKED FIFTH
IN THE NATION DEFENSE IN THE
TOP 20 IN OFFENSE, AND
I THINK OVERALL
PAUL WRITING NOW IS SIX IN
THE NATION SO, YOU KNOW THAT
IT WAS JUST AN UNCALLED FOR
COMMENT FOR SOMEONE WHO
PROBABLY NEVER SEEN US PLAY.
WELL, I THOUGHT YOU HANDLED
IT. WELL, IT WAS PROBABLY
BERKELEY JUST BLAME IT ON
BERKELEY THE GAMES. ANYWAY,
BERKELEY IS GREAT. I LOVE
CHARLES BARKLEY. YEAH, HE'S
THE BEST. SO NOW DEFINITELY
WASN'T HIM. HE'S GREAT. WELL,
LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT THE
MOBLEY FAMILY HAS BEEN PRETTY
GOOD FOR YOU. YOU GOT A COACH
ON YOUR STAFF. YOU GOT YOU
KNOW, EVAN WHO'S GOING TO BE
IN SHORT OF SPECTACULAR BUT
BIG BRO, ISAIAH HAS BEEN
REALLY REALLY GOOD FOR YOU
GUYS IN THE TOURNAMENT.
WELL, THE WHOLE MOBLEY FAMILY
IS SPECIAL FROM NICOLE THE
MOTHER SHE WAS THERE WITH HER
SOME OF HER RELATIVES AND
COACH MOBLEY. ERIC HAS DONE A
GREAT JOB. HE'S BEEN OUR
STAFF FOR THREE YEARS ISAIAH
CAME TWO YEARS AGO AND
HAVEN'T OF COURSE THIS YEAR,
BUT EVAN AND ISAIAH HAVE
IMPROVED SO MUCH AS PLAYERS,
BUT THE GREATEST THING I CAN
SAY ABOUT THOSE GUYS ARE JUST
WINNERS THAT THEY THEY'RE
THEY DON'T HAVE AN EGO THERE.
THEY JUST PLAY TEAM
BASKETBALL AND AND WE'RE A
TEAM ISAIAH AND EVAN ARE
PLAYING WELL, BUT SO ARE ALL
THE OTHER GUYS AND
THEY'RE THE FIRST TWO GUYS
TOGETHER TEAMMATES CREDIT AND
THEY REST OF THE TEAM AND SO
IT'S GREAT TO SEE HEAVEN AND
ISAIAH IMPROVED SO MUCH AND
TAKE THE LEADERSHIP, BUT
WE'RE REALLY PLAYING WELL AS
A TEAM RIGHT NOW. THIS IS
THIS IS WHERE YOU WANT TO BE
AS A COACH YOU LEAVE FLORIDA
GULF COAST YOU COME TO LOS
ANGELES. I THINK WE LIVE IN
THE SAME GENERAL VICINITY AND
YOU MAKE THE TREK EVERY DAY
UP TO USC AND IT'S OBVIOUSLY
IT'S WELL KNOWN THAT THE U.S.
SEES A FOOTBALL SCHOOL. I
WENT TO A TENNIS
SEE, IT'S A FOOTBALL SCHOOL.
THAT'S PRODUCED SOME REALLY
GOOD BASKETBALL TEAMS OVER
THE YEARS BUT ONE OF THE HARD
THINGS THAT USC IS BEING
CONSISTENTLY GOOD YEAR IN AND
YEAR OUT IN BASKETBALL. DO
YOU THINK THIS IS THE STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION FOR YOU
GUYS TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT?
OBVIOUSLY YOU'VE HAD SUCCESS
SINCE YOU'VE BEEN HERE, BUT
THE FIRST SWEET 16 FOR THE
SCHOOL SINCE I WAS SEVEN.
YEAH, WE UNDERSTAND THE
DIFFICULTY. LOOK I WAS AT
FLORIDA STATE AS AN ASSISTANT
COACH FOR FIVE YEARS WITH
LEONARD HAMILTON. THAT'S A
FOOTBALL SCHOOL AS WELL. I
LOVE FOOTBALL MY WIFE AMANDA
LOVES FOOTBALL COLLEGE
FOOTBALL.
ALSO, WE REALLY ROOT FOR THE
TROJANS AND AND THEIR
FOOTBALL PROGRAM AND I THINK
WHEN THEY DO, WELL IT HELPS
THE ENTIRE SCHOOL. IT HELPS
THE NATIONAL BRAND, BUT THE
SAME TIME IT DOESN'T HELP YOU
WIN BASKETBALL GAMES BECAUSE
YOU HAVE A GOOD FOOTBALL TEAM.
YOU HAVE TO GO DO THAT.
YOU'RE ON YOUR OWN AND SO I
THINK WHAT REALLY HAS BEEN
DIFFICULT OR WAS DIFFICULT
WHEN WE FIRST TOOK THE JOB
WAS JUST THE LACK OF
SUSTAINED SUCCESS IN THE USC
BASKETBALL PROGRAM OVER THE
HISTORY OF IT BECAUSE THERE'S
BEEN SOME GREAT COACHES AND
PLAYERS OVER TWO GREAT TEAMS.
YES, BUT THE LACK OF
SUSTAINED SUCCESS FOR THE
TRADITION. SO WHEN YOU GO
PLAY A KANSAS AS HAD DECADES
AND DECADES OF THAT TRADITION
AND THE SUSTAINED SUCCESS,
IT'S A WHOLE DIFFERENT TYPE
OF PROGRAM AND THE FAN
SUPPORT. SO WE'RE DOING OUR
BEST TO TRY TO SUSTAIN THAT
SUCCESS. WE LAST SIX YEARS. I
THINK WE'RE 14TH OR 15TH IN
THE COUNTRY AND WINS AMONG
THE POWER FIVE CONFERENCE AS
I THINK WE HAVE A HUNDRED
THIRTY THREE WINS LAST TWO
YEARS WERE 46 + 16, WHICH IS
THIRD IN THE NATION IN WINS
AMONG THE 6 POWER CONFERENCES
BEHIND BAYLOR AND
AS A SODA FOR USC TO BE 46
AND 16A LAST TWO YEARS.
THAT'S A CREDIT TO OUR
PLAYERS. THEY JUST DONE A
TERRIFIC JOB. IT'S BEEN A
MINUTE FOR YOU GUYS. SINCE
YOU WERE IN THE ELITE 8. I
THINK IT WAS BRIAN SCALABRINE
STEAM BACK IN 2000 2001 ISH.
HAVE YOU HEARD FROM ANYBODY
FROM FROM THAT TEAM? WHO'S
ROOTING FOR YOU GUYS TO GET
BACK THERE? I GET SOME TEXT.
I KNOW OUR ASSISTANT COACHES
DESMOND FARMER WHO PLAYED AN
IDEAL EAT TAME. HE'S A
GRADUATE ASSISTANT FOR US NOW,
SO HE GETS A LOT OF HE KNOWS
THOSE GUYS BECAUSE HE WAS ON
THAT TEAM.
MMMMM. I JUST GOT A CALL FROM
A MOLD LATENT TODAY WHO IS A
LEGEND AND USC HOOPS. HE
PLAYED WITH WEST WALL BEFORE
PAUL. I GUESS IN THE SAME
TEAM AND AND FOLATE AND WAS
REALLY ONE OF THE GUYS TO
START SOME OF THAT SUCCESS.
SO IT IS NICE TO HEAR FROM
THE EX TROJANS. I'VE HAD SOME
EXTRA COACHES REACH OUT TO ME.
AND SO THAT'S REALLY NICE. I
THINK EVERYONE'S ROOTING FOR
OUR PLAYERS. WE GOT A SPECIAL
TEAM THIS YEAR. YEAH. IT'S
BEEN A FUN TEAM TO WATCH.
I'VE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WATCH YOU GUYS A LITTLE BIT.
I SAID BEING IN THE AREA THE
OF TO TO LA FROM FROM FLORIDA
GULF COAST FOR YOU HAVE THERE
BEEN ANY MOMENTS WHEN YOU
LOOK UP IN THE STANDS AT A
GAME OR YOU'RE SITTING THERE
AT THE MANHATTAN COUNTRY CLUB
WATCHING MARIA SHARAPOVA PLAY
TENNIS AND YOU'RE SAYING MAN
THIS THERE YOU'RE SEEING
STAR-STUDDED PERSON THAT YOU
MAY NOT HAVE EXPECTED TO SEE
ON THAT PARTICULAR DAY. GIVE
ME ONE OF THOSE LA MOMENTS.
WELL, I PROBABLY SAY IT'S
WHEN I GO TO THE BEACH AND I
SEE THE THE OLYMPIC BEACH
VOLLEYBALL PLAYERS AND THAT
LOT BETTER ATHLETE THAN I
EVER WAS OR EVER WILL BE SO
BUT BUT YOU KNOW, YOU DO SEE
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THAT
THE LOS ANGELES AREA IS A
GREAT PLACE TO LIVE. WE LOVE
THE LIFESTYLE MY WIFE AND OUR
FAMILY AND AND WE JUST HAVE A
LOT OF FRIENDS THAT ARE IN
THE ENTERTAINMENT THE SPORTS
BUSINESS AND JUST PEOPLE THAT
ARE WE'VE MET ALONG THE WAY
THEY'RE JUST TERRIFIC FAMILY.
SO WE REALLY ENJOY THE AREA
MY LAST QUESTION COACH FOR WE
LET YOU GO. YOU GOT TO OREGON
COMING UP. YOU'RE GOING TO
PLAY THEM AGAIN. YOU PLAYED
THEM DURING THE REGULAR
SEASON YOU
WON THAT GAME I'VE HEARD YOUR
QUOTE. HEY, YOU KNOW, WE'D
RATHER NOT PLAY ORGAN A
CONFERENCE TEAM THAT WE'VE
PLAYED BEFORE. HE'D RATHER
PLAY SOMEBODY OUT OF THE
PAC-12, BUT THE GOOD NEWS IS
THAT NO MATTER WHAT HAPPENS
IS IN THIS GAME. IT WILL BE A
PAC-12 TEAM AND THEY LEAD 8,
YOU DON'T YOU DON'T REALLY
MEAN THAT YOU DON'T CARE IF
MORGAN GOES TO THE LEAD A YOU
WANT TO GET IN THE ELITE,
RIGHT? I MEAN, IT SOUNDS GOOD
IN THEORY. WELL, OF COURSE WE
WOULD LIKE TO WIN THAT GAME,
BUT I WAS JUST CONFUSED OF
HOW OREGON A TO TO LEAGUE
TEAMS CAN PLAY EACH OTHER IN
THE
AT 16 SO I WAS CONFUSED ON
HOW THAT HAPPENS. I'M NOT I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THIS THIS
SELECTION COMMITTEE OR THE
CRITERIA HOW THEY SEE TEAMS
OR WHAT BRACKETS THEY PUT
THEM IN. SO I APOLOGIZE. I
JUST DON'T KNOW ENOUGH
INFORMATION TO COMMENT ON
THAT. BUT OREGON HAS A
TREMENDOUS TEAM. AND THE
REASON I SAID WHAT I SAID
YESTERDAY WAS I THINK IT IS
UNFORTUNATE FOR THE PAC-12
FOR US TO HAVE TO PLAY OR
AGAIN BECAUSE WE'RE FIRST IN
THE OREGON WAS FIRST WE WERE
SECOND IN THE LEAGUE AND TO
HAVE THE FIRST AND
TEAMS PLAY IN THE SWEET 16 IS
NOT IDEAL BECAUSE MARCH
MADNESS IS ALL ABOUT PLAYING
TEAMS FROM OTHER CONFERENCES
AND PLAYING TEAMS. YOU'VE
NEVER PLAYED BEFORE OR
HAVEN'T PLAYED IN A WHILE, SO
BE AN IT'LL BE A HECK OF A
GAME TWO GOOD TEAMS GOING AT
IT FROM THE SAME LINEAGE AND
WE'LL DO OUR BEST. HEY
SPEAKING OF THE LEAGUE. I
LIKE TO HAVE ONE MORE
QUESTION. THE PAC-12 HAS BEEN
SO GOOD. I MEAN SURPRISINGLY
GOOD AND THIS TOURNAMENT DID
GUYS GOT FOUR TEAMS INTO THE
SWEET 16
I THINK IT'S SURPRISING BUT
IT'S NOT SURPRISING IN THE
FACT THAT WE HAVE A REALLY
GOOD LEAGUE AND THE TEAM'S
WE'VE BEEN THE TEAMS IN OUR
LEAGUE OBVIOUSLY CAN BEAT
ANYBODY ELSE IN THE COUNTRY
ON A GIVEN NIGHT AND YOU'VE
SEEN THAT WE'RE NOT IN ONE
AND ALLOW FOR IN THE SWEET 16.
SO I THINK IF YOU WOULD HAVE
SAID HEY FOUR OUT OF THE FIVE
TEAMS ARE GOING TO GO TO THE
SWEET 16. I THINK A LOT OF
PEOPLE BE SURPRISED ME
INCLUDED BUT BECAUSE BUT
PLEASANTLY SURPRISED BUT I'M
NOT SURPRISED AT THE LEVEL
OF PLAY BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN
BATTLING THESE TEAMS ALL YEAR.
LONG AND WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO
TELL THE MEDIA OPTION THE
EAST COAST SO I NEVER SAW USC
BASKETBALL GAME GROWING UP. I
SAW USC FOOTBALL AND SATURDAY
AFTERNOON. I LOVE THE
CARDINAL AND GOLD JERSEYS AND
THAT WAS MY FAVORITE FOOTBALL
UNIFORM, BUT THAT WAS BECAUSE
IT WAS ON SUNDAY AFTERNOONS.
I NEVER SAW USC BASKETBALL
GAME ON THE EAST COAST
BECAUSE THE GAME STARTED
SEVEN OR EIGHT O'CLOCK AND
YOU JUST DON'T FOLLOW THE
PAC-12. SO I THINK THE PAC-12
IS NOT APPRECIATED ENOUGH ON
A NATIONAL SCALE JUST BECAUSE
OF THE TIME DIFFERENCE AND THE
IN THE LACK OF
OF EXPOSURE AND TO THE EAST
COAST INTO THE MIDWEST SO OUR
LEAGUE WAS REALLY GOOD LAST
YEAR. WE HAD SIX TEAMS AND
TOURNAMENT LAST YEAR AS WELL
PUT 10 DRAFT PICKS IN THE NBA
LAST YEAR. AND SO NOW YOU'RE
SEEING SOME REALLY GOOD
YOU'RE SEEING SOME REALLY
GOOD BASKETBALL TEAMS ADVANCE
AND I'M HAPPY FOR OUR LEAGUE
BACK IN THE SWEET 16 IS USC
FOR THE FIRST TIME SINCE O7
TRYING TO GET TO THE ELITE
EIGHT FOR THE FIRST TIME
SINCE 2001 AND IAIN FIELD
. CONGRATULATIONS ANDY, IT'S
BEEN FUN TO WATCH YOU GUYS
PLAY. IT REALLY IS A FUN
TEAM. YOU GUYS ARE PLAYING
SOME LOCKDOWN DEFENSE YOUR
THE THREE BALL GOOD LUCK THE
REST OF THE WAY. THANK YOU